am sonntag übermorgen ist übrigens nicht
nur europawahl sondern auch bremen war
und wenn sie jetzt sagen das ist ja
ungefähr so interessant wie wenn in
bremen man sagt fischbrötchen umfeld
eben nicht freunde an dieser besseren
kommunalwahl da oben kann die groko
sterben
zumindest wenn die spd bremen verliert
mit ihrem spitzenkandidaten
wer weiß es man amtierender
bürgermeister kennen sie den namen des
bremer bürgermeisters
auch wissen sie jetzt sehr hier solche
examinierten ich kenne den namen unserer
spitzenkandidatin das gemein
[Gelächter]
ich weiß es nicht der mich ertappt
ja ich kenne auch ja ich kenne ihn aber
ich sage ihnen nicht mehr heißt ich weiß
es er ist carsten sieling habe ich mit
google also mich und ich sehe den
bürgermeister war nicht mal er selbst
kennt seinen namen und personen liegt in
aktuellen umfragen hinter der cdu und
das ist in bremen eigentlich verboten ja
nach 73 jahren ununterbrochener
spd-regierung 73 jahre der wahnsinn der
bremen-wahl symbolisch dargestellt der
unionskandidat heißt übrigens auch
carsten karsten maier jeder bremen ist
offensichtlich so haben die können sich
nur einen vornamen leisten
bei jeder liegt vorn und dabei ist er
erst letztes jahr in die cdu eingetreten
unternehmer und selfmade man mit
erstaunlich entspannte attitüde was das
fachliche angeht manchmal auch mut zur
lücke bei ihnen
naja ich bin halt für einsteiger ich
möchte das ist das ist meine challenge
jetzt so sagen ich bin ich bearbeite
mich da auch eine die themen und ich
will ja auch ehrlich gesagt nur
bürgermeister geben
eben ist ja nicht so dass es sich um
richtigen job bewirbt hier sein neues
cdu plakat sehr gut gewählt wir nicht
aber solche leute
tatsache ist aber auch solche leute will
der wähler heutzutage haben
quereinsteiger sind die neuen stars je
weniger erfahrung desto besser
weil das gibt es bei keinem anderen
beruf dass man sagt dem vertraulich
bleiben er hat auch noch nie gemacht
wann wussten sie denn dass sie die
politik lieber zum beruf machen wollen
das ist ein schleichender prozess ich
möchte ja die politik auch gleich zu
meinem beruf machen also ich habe nach
wie vor die firma ja aber du weißt schon
wenn du die wahl gewinnt dann ist das
dein beruf dann musst du nicht weiß das
wünscht man keinem tatsächlich bremen
regieren tut mir leid wo er auch nicht
alle schlecht läuft es gibt ja auch
positive nachrichten das
wirtschaftswachstum liegt aktuell über
dem bundesschnitt autobranche
raumfahrtindustrie
andererseits eben auch 21,6 milliarden
euro schulden ja die höchste die höchste
pro kopf verschuldung deutschlands
christoph maria herbst entführt uns mit
seinem reisebericht in die sympathische
favela an der weser
[Musik]
während die deutschen bundesländer die
kinder der kelly family
dann wäre bremen angelo das kleine
hässliche das immer vergessen wird oder
lassen sie mich klaus wowereit
modifizieren bremen ist arm aber ungeil
schüler bei der pisa-studie hat uns
bremen mal so richtig reingeritten ich
stehe gerade vor dem otto rehhagel
gymnasium dir sind auch montag dienstag
und mittwoch frei dsv future jeder
dritte viertklässler kann ich richtig
lesen jeder vierte drittklässler kann
ich richtig rechnen mit einem zeugnis
aus bremen kann man eigentlich nur eins
werden lehrer in bremen entschuldigung
sind sie leer war
ich glaube mit dem schreiben sieht es
finster aus wer hafen mit v schreibt der
schreibt auch vögel mit f und pfütze mit
wenn sie verstehen was ich meine
das ist das eigentliche wahrzeichen von
bremen sozusagen der berliner flughafen
als autobahn in bremen die a281 wobei
die zahl 281 für die anzahl der jahre
steht die die bauzeit dauert 34 jahre
sind immerhin schon vor über eine lange
zeit damals war gerhard schröder noch
sozialdemokrat und damit sind wir beim
grund für die bremer misere wird nämlich
einfach solange gewählt bis die richtige
partei am ruder ist an die das war
istanbul
hier wählen die leute einfach alle
freiwillig die spd und zwar nicht einmal
zweimal oder dreimal sondern immer und
es liegt natürlich auch an den
alternativen ich sag mal so cdu wenn du
50 jahre lang fußball spielst gegen
einbeinige die größtenteils auch noch
blind sind und trotzdem immer verlierst
dann solltest du vielleicht aufhören
mitzuspielen
[Gelächter]
bremen ist praktisch dass griechenland
deutschlands und man muss sich um diese
schulden auch nicht wundern wenn man
hier sogar der faulheit ein denkmal
setzt der schuldenberg bremens wächst
pro sekunde um 43 cent lassen 37.000
euro am tag 13 millionen im jahr
damit es bremen quasi das boris becker
unter den deutschen städten oder der
gebotene radio sieht es ähnlich aus
unserem bobbele man kann also sagen
kinder arbeit eher nicht so
natürlich mit dem bogen um bremen die
ist ja nicht bescheuert
[Musik]
da
christoph matschie
mit hausverbot und reden habe ich viele
freunde gemacht
und ja leider war vor allem die bremer
bildungspolitik kriegt in der tat sehr
sehr schlechte noten ja ja ist kein
wunder dass sie kaum neue lehrer finden
die da oben hin wollen andererseits
liegt die afc in bremen bei gerade mal
sieben prozent also so durch können die
bremer nicht sein bremens problem ist
dass sie ein bundesland sein wollen ohne
landesregierung könnten wie jedes jahr
bis zu 100 millionen euro sparen um mehr
licht braucht bremen wirklich einen
eigenen fernsehsender
wobei ich zugeben muss die wahl sendung
von radio bremen sind mit abstand die
besten so schön strukturiert die
buletten bremer spitzenkandidaten hört
sich einfach nicht hin zum kochen ist
die lösung ist nur noch ein spiel haben
[Musik]
dieses lassen sie mal nicht das lassen
sie mal in der tat lassen sie mal lieber
frage wie könnte man bankrotten
stadtstaaten wie bremen helfen reden wir
drüber mit alexander wipprecht von der
heute-show abteilung für frische ideen
die außer uns absurderweise noch keiner
hatte david precht was ist die lösung
all das kann ich ihnen sagen oli
die lösung heißt aufräumen unser
grundgesetz ist gerade 70 geworden und
von uns gibt als geschenk eine
kostenlose entwicklung herzlich
willkommen zu der hund zwischen
frühjahrsputz alles muss raus
heute.de realismus
[Musik]
da guckt ihr dürfen klar förderalismus
das steht so im grundgesetz sogar mit
ewigkeit klausel aber nicht ewig freunde
kommt muss nehmen was hier gesagt ja wir
haben es 70 jahre probiert es
funktioniert nicht
beispiel bildung 16 verschiedene
schulsysteme g8 g9 zweig streit
wieso nehmen es hin dass er den lehrer
aus klatschen
aber wieso nehmen wir es hin dass ein
junger mann mit einser abitur zeugnis
aus nrw gerade mal qualifiziert ist
damit in bayern toiletten zu putzen
das ist doch der kern unseres be silence
diese ganzen experimente am offenen
kinder hören und was dabei rauskommt das
sieht man ja jeden tag im fernsehen wie
viel menschen leben denn in der eu also
allein in deutschland leben ja schon
65.000 wird jetzt mal sich drei
millionen vielleicht wie heißt der
höchste berg deutschlands
naja da aber in bremen kriegt man
immerhin für die antwort noch nur zwei -
41 17 regierungen 145 ministerium 17
parlamente 2500 parlamentariern
natürlich hat jedes bundesland einen
eigenen verfassungsschutz sogar das
saarland hier das ist der
verfassungsschutz vom saarland eine oma
in saarbrücken die islamisten wenn sie
falsch parken und wenn's mal darauf
ankommt wie damals im fall amri dann
können wir uns immerhin darauf verlassen
dass all diese behörde null kommen wir
gar nichts zusammen arbeiten
wir haben 16 verschiedene bauordnungen
in niedersachsen da brauchst du für
einen carport eine baugenehmigung in
meck-pomm nicht aber dafür müssen 20
schafe darunter post
da bist du bescheuert und ständig
irgendwo wahlkampf neben mir reicht das
jetzt na ja ich habe mit zentralismus
hat man ja auch schon mal unschöne
erfahrungen wegen hier ja ja ja ja schon
klar
man braucht bundesländer aber weniger
und da gibt es doch immer wieder seriöse
ideen hier das acht länder
modellvorschlag von 1995
oder dass sechs länder modell idee von
2006 und weiß was ich würde sogar vier
runter gehen hier in der mitte nord
rheinland pfalz im norden fischkopp land
rechts die zone und unten die idee mal
so komisch reden ja
[Applaus]
ja oder natürlich der klassiker aldi
nord und aldi süd michael beschreibt auf
facebook wilke du bist der letzte arsch
nur große fresse ich möchte ich mal
sehen wenn es hart auf hart kommt dann
schaust du dir in die hose warte ab ein
sprichwort sagt man trifft sich immer
zweimal im leben mach weiter so mit
einer großen fresse wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zwei oder hier auf
youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren